this christmas the most heartwarming
show on television is back you can't
help but feel lifted just being here and
it's loyal fans are getting a very
special present i'm morgan kohan hey i'm
marsha williams hi i'm jefferson brown
rj hathanaka we are on the set of when
hope calls christmas join us this sunday
at 10 eastern for a gac family special
presentation when hope calls hardy's
christmas present if you enjoyed season
one you're really going to enjoy the
special that they're cooking up
take a sneak peek at what's changing in
brookfield this season we have some
exciting stuff between gabriel and
lillian i'm really excited to figure out
more of that who vincent is we've got a
couple new people coming to brookfield
that are very unexpected
exclusive interviews it just feels like
the big warm hug when you come up here
it means a lot to lucy
to have tess as a role model on the
ranch for work but also
as a motherly figure best of all the
cast answers questions directly from our
loyal fan base of hearties hi bruce and
cindy thank you for joining a hearty
event hi kim thank you so much for your
question lori first off thank you for
noticing the beer it's a christmas
present like no other from the fun
between the takes and just
be prepared for the most hilarious
dancing
are there any
other than this one
fun and candid moments that you've had
between each other on set anything any
fun story that you can tell us
that we can tell you
to personal holiday memories one of my
favorite things to eat at christmas is
one of my mom's specialties the four of
us used to get up very very early and do
the whole sneaking downstairs thing
that's how crazy christmas and you can
be a part of the excitement by sharing
on social media at hashtag hardy's
christmas present very very excited to
um
to get back out there in front of the
hardys be here for a very special
holiday presentation when hope calls
hardy's christmas present sunday at 10
p.m eastern on gac family i feel like
with every story line there's something
for everyone and join gac family for a
two-part special that will bring hope to
the hearts of all from our christmas
tree to yours merry christmas from gac
family the home of great american
christmas
it all leads up to the season premiere
of when hope calls saturday december
18th on gac family
[Music]
you